seit knapp einem monat leicht
afghanistan einer taliban hülle die
menschen die es nicht rechtzeitig
geschafft haben zu flüchten die bangen
um ihr leben jeden tag aus der
afghanischen hauptstadt häufen sich
berichte die das brutale vorgehen der
taliban gegen demonstranten gegen frauen
und gegen journalisten belegen ja prügel
festnahmen und folter und es ist
unglaublich wenn man sich vorstellt wie
kurz diese zeit erst ist in der das
alles passiert ist wir wollen uns das
mal in zeitstrahl auf unserem
touchscreen hier anschauen also wie
gesagt am 15 august haben die taliban im
prinzip in kabul die macht übernommen
und wir erinnern uns alle an die bilder
einen tag später versuchen verzweifelte
menschen aus kabul zu fliehen aus dem
flughafen versuchen sich hier an eine
amerikanische maschine zu hängen
dramatische bilder natürlich schaffen
wir es nicht tatsächlich sind auch
menschen aus der luft von der maschine
herunter gefallen das war am 16 august
was andere bild das natürlich sich
eingebrannt hat ins kollektive
gedächtnis wie afghanen hier in ihrer
verzweiflung ein krankes baby über den
stacheldrahtzaun am flughafen in kabul
an amerikanische soldaten weitergeben in
der hoffnung ist irgendwie zu retten wir
wissen inzwischen dass dieses baby von
norwegischen sanitätern behandelt wurde
und ihnen dann gesund zurück gegeben
werden konnte das ist das andere bild
sechsundzwanzigster august ein
selbstmordattentäter zwei attentäter
sprengten sich in der menge der
tausenden wartenden menschen vor dem
flughafen in kabul in die luft 60
afghanen sind dabei gestorben auch 13
amerikanische soldaten sind gestorben
wir gehen weiter am 29 august eine
dramatische szene die alles zeigt ein
afghanischer nachrichtensprecher kann
nicht mehr frei berichten zwei taliban
stehen daneben und natürlich kann er nur
noch das sagen was sie wollen wir gehen
weiter
wir gehen weiter hier und schauen auf
den siebter september da sehen wir wie
zum ersten mal menschen auf der straße
geschlagen werden nicht zum ersten mal
aber wir sehen ist hier zum ersten mal
mit stöcken geschlagen
brutale szenen genau das was man von den
taliban eigentlich erwartet hatte obwohl
sie versprochen hatten dass sie
solche methoden nicht mehr an wurden
anwenden wollten und sich konziliant
gegenüber dem westen gezeigt haben und
hier das letzte bild am 12 september die
neue regelung des studiums an den
universitäten auch frauen dürfen
weiterhin studieren aber eben nicht mehr
zusammen mit männern sondern nur
getrennt und sie müssen dabei voll
verschleiert sein tatsächlich gibt es
sogar gerüchte dass unter diesen
propaganda bildern diese seine frau die
sich positiv darüber äußert gar keine
frauen steckten sondern womöglich männer
patricia
prügel festnahmen und folter die stehen
auf der tagesordnung in afghanistan
unser reporter paul ronzheimer ist seit
wochen im land unterwegs und er hat
jetzt ganz exklusiv einen ort besucht er
jetzt auch den taliban gehört und dort
kündigen sie jetzt schon an mit welcher
brutalität sie durch schreiben werden
bild im knast der taliban leere zellen
und ein muffiger geruch
ein kämpfer er steht mit einem
sturmgewehr in einem gefängnis gang
wache dass polygamie ist das größte
gefängnis in afghanistan wo sonst
tausende taliban kämpfer ihre strafe
abgesessen haben herrscht jetzt leere
sie alle wurden von den taliban frei
gelassen bild reporter paul ronzheimer
ist vor ort will der welt zeigen wie
dramatisch die lage in afghanistan ist
und wird exklusiv durch die zellen des
gefängnisses geführt wie dort gefoltert
wurde das lässt sich nur noch erahnen
unser bild reporter spricht mit
gefängnischef malawi
was glauben sie ist das beste
justizsystem wenn menschen ins gefängnis
müssen oder wenn das gericht entscheidet
dass ein finger oder eine hand
abgeschnitten werden muss oder jemand
getötet werden soll
es wird die scharia gelten so wie wir
sie kennen wenn jemand sünde begeht ist
die strafe meist eine hand abzuschneiden
wenn die person eine ehebruch begeht und
keine frau oder ein mann hat dann gibt
es schläge für sie mit einer dora wenn
sie eine frau oder ein mann haben und
sie immer noch ehebruch begehen dann
wird die strafe der tod sein
und wenn sie sie schlagen einen finger
abschneiden oder töten würde das hier
passieren oder an einem anderen ort
in richtung würden an einem öffentlichen
ort geschehen wir würden die
öffentlichkeit dazu einladen es würde
gesagt werden welche sünde die personen
begangen hat und was die strafe dafür
ist wie viele menschen sollen versammelt
sein wenn das geschieht
es werden hunderte oder tausende leute
versammelt sein wie das gesetz der
taliban aussieht ist auch nach einem
monat nach der machtübernahme immer noch
unklar die taliban spitze hat erklärt
dass schon bald die scharia gelten soll
und wir wollen jetzt mit dem ansprechen
der für uns seit wochen aus der taliban
hölle berichtet und in dem größten
gefängnis afghanistan es war halo paul
paul diese unfassbaren bilder die du uns
mitgebracht hast wird sich das angefühlt
in diesem gefängnis zu sein und die
taliban zu hören welche gräueltaten sie
da jetzt schon ankündigen
kritisiert das war wirklich so real dort
durchzulaufen du musst wissen in diesem
gefängnis waren einst über
250 ehemalige
guantanamo-häftlinge in diesem gefängnis
das bedeutet die schlimmsten terroristen
also die die von den usa dann nach
afghanistan gebracht wurden in den
vergangenen jahren insgesamt waren
tausende taliban kämpfer dort und die
alle wurden einfach frei gelassen auf
meine frage hin aber was ist wenn da
jetzt was passiert was es mit den
kriminellen mit denjenigen die menschen
getötet haben da sagte mir der
gefängnischef die wissen ja was ihnen
droht damit meint er die scharia und er
hat fast freudig angekündigt dass er
glaubt dass es bald losgehen könnte also
dass es hinrichtungen gibt hier wo ich
stehe patricia in kabul gab es das
zuletzt 1996 in großem umfang auch
damals haben die taliban regiert damals
wurden menschen eingeladen ins stadion
um dabei zu sein wie frauen wie männer
hingerichtet wurden
weil das heißt man muss tatsächlich
davon ausgehen dass solche zustände in
kurzer zeit wieder eintreten werden
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass es diese
hinrichtung wiedergibt dass es das
worauf diejenigen die mit den taliban
gekämpft haben die für die taliban
gekämpft haben seit jahrzehnten warten
das ist das was sie uns immer wieder
sagen das war unser ziel die scharia für
afghanistan deswegen geht da überhaupt
kein weg dran vorbei und wenn wir uns
anhören was zum einen die
taliban-anführer sagen und dann zum
anderen diejenigen sagen die ich hier
überall im land treffe von den taliban
also die dort im gefängnis standen die
man in checkpoints trifft die man auf
den dörfern sieht die sind in ihrer
brutalität kaum zu beschreiben die
wollen diese gewalt die wollen dass sich
das land so ändert wie sie es immer
erklärt bekommen haben und da kann aus
dem westen noch so viel aussagen kommen
dass man darauf hofft dass sie sich
irgendwie verändert haben nein meine
meinung ist das was ich hier erlebt habe
in den vergangenen wochen die taliban
haben sich nicht verändert die sind
genauso radikal ihre ideologie ist
gleich geblieben und wir im westen sind
naiv wenn wir glauben dass sich
irgendwas ändern würde das geht
vielleicht lang mal das passiert nicht
sofort nicht jetzt aber in ein paar
monaten in jahren werden wir den ganzen
das ganze grauen die ganzen horror sie
warum haben die taliban sich überhaupt
in das gefängnis hineingelassen das sind
ja keine steinzeitmenschen wie wir immer
so einfach sagen sondern das sind ja
mittlerweile moderne propagandisten die
wissen ja welchen eindrücke entstehen
wenn wir diese bilder sehen
die taliban hatten die hoffnung dass wir
darauf uns konzentrieren würden was
angeblich ihren kämpfern dort angetan
wurde also als sie uns dort durchgeführt
haben haben sie immer wieder gesagt wie
die afghanische armee dort angeblich
gefoltert hat das ist auch durchaus
möglich durchaus realistisch da gab es
immer wieder diese berichte über
entsprechende satz ionen aber für uns
als reporter ist das in dem moment
natürlich schwer überprüfbar denn es
gibt keine beweise es gibt nicht
diejenigen mehr die dort waren die sind
geflüchtet oder im versteck und wir
haben danach gefragt was sie denn wollen
was mit der scharia ist was dann
passiert und da hatten sie auch kein
problem offen darauf zu antworten denn
es ist das was sie wirklich wollen und
da machen vor allem diejenigen die bei
den taliban wie soll man sagen für die
basis stehen eventuell also für
diejenigen die den durchschnitt ergeben
die sagen dort die wahrheit im gegensatz
zu den glaube ich die dort an der spitze
stehen die versuchen sich durch
diplomatische aussagen irgendwie in
richtung westen gut zu stellen
anordnungen von unserem reporter paul
ronzheimer live aus kabul danke
[Musik]